i want you to pause this video and
figure out if you can figure out the
area of this quadrilateral right over
here and i'll give you a hint try to
break it up into
into shapes where it is easier to find
the area especially given the grid of
these unit squares that we have right
over here
so assume you gave it a go now let's try
to do it together so i'm going to start
at at points where
we will be very easy to measure very
easy to measure the the dimensions of
whatever figures we might break it up at
and so in general i want to go to any of
the whole numbers of these of these
units so that point right over there and
let's see i could start to move in this
direction
i could start to move in this direction
and it looks like i might be able to
construct a triangle down here
and it would be tempting to go all the
way across but that wouldn't be too
useful because this gets me to kind of
halfway through a unit and i'm just
eyeballing it to say halfway through
unit it might not be exactly halfway
through a unit and so instead let me see
if i can get away with making a triangle
just like that
now i just did that so let me try to
raise
this up to see if i can
if i can make another triangle where it
would be easy to figure out its
dimensions so once again i don't want to
go all the way up here because now i'm
not at a at kind of a whole unit instead
let me take a right and go right over
here
and notice both of these are pretty easy
or they're very easy to figure out
dimensions this is
one two three four five units long
and one unit high this one right over
here is one two three four units high
and two or four units long and one two
two units wide so let's see if we can if
we can map out the entire if we can
cover the entire square or the entire
quadrilateral we can break it up i
should say into a bunch of figures like
this so it seems like we have another
one just like that and then i could drop
this down
and then we're done all of these are
pretty straightforward to figure out
what their dimensions are this is five
by one this is four by two this is one
two three four five six
by one two
and this is one by one two three four
five
so what are what is the area of this
figure and of course we have this center
rectangle right over here
well a triangle
that is five units long and one unit
high its area is going to be one half
times one
times five
or i could write it
one half times one times five depending
on what multiplication symbol you are
more comfortable with well that's just
going to be one half times five which is
going to be equal to 2.5
so that's 2.5 right over there
this one is going to be one half
times four times two well that's just
going to be 2 times 2 or 4.
this one is going to be 1 half times 2
times 1 2 3 4 5 6. well one half times 2
is 1 times 6 is just 6.
and then this was going to be one half
times 1 times
1 2 3 4 5. so once again the area of
this one is going to be 2.5
and then finally this is a 3
by 4
rectangle and you can even count the
unit squares in here but it has 12 of
those units squared so it has an area of
12. so if we want to find the total area
we just add all of these together so 2.5
plus 2.5 is 5 plus 4 is 9 plus 6 is 15
plus 12 is 27 so it has a total area
of 27.